na kennen Sie das auch sie haben sich
zwei Karten für ihren absoluten
Lieblingsfilm ergattert und freuen sich
auf einen perfekten kinoaben mit ihrer
liebsten aber gerade als es losgehen
soll setzen sich ausgerechnet ein lulat
eine Bohnenstange und Godzillas großer
Bruder direkt auf die Plätze vor ihrer
Nase und machen ihren wunderschönen
Abend zu zwei zu nichte aber das muss
nicht sein denn jetzt gibt es endlich
den kleine leuteeverleih ja der kleine
ab sofort auch in ihrer Stadt Schloss
mit Frost und mieser Sicht Lein sich
einfach ein paar kleine Leute aus für
die sitzrei vor ihnen und genießen Sie
ungestört ihren nächsten Kino Konzert
oder Theaterbesuch
garantiert der kleine leuteverleih
bietet kleine Leute für jede Gelegenheit
in den Größen klein verdammt klein und
glitze glitze Klein der kleine Leute
kleine Idee mit großer Wirkung und jetzt
ganz neu im Programm für Selbstvertrauen
damit sie nicht immer wieder letzte DEP
auf jeder Party Wirken der hässliche
Leute Verleih und sie wirken wie Brad
Pitt und Angelina Julie also worauf
warten Sie noch rufen Sie sofort an ihr
kleine Leute und hässliche Leute verlei
freut sich auf Ihren
[Applaus]
Anruf